Speaker 1: Let's go instead. To Keaton from
San Jose. Keaton, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today? And
you do have to unmute yourself.
Speaker 2: KEATON Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Great. Yes. So
you had talked about this.
During the the midterms and 2020.
And I'm curious as to what you mean.
When you say Democrats need to be on the offense.
Speaker 1: Yeah. You're that's you're just curious
what I mean by that. Yeah, I guess.
Speaker 2: Strategically
communicated typically what that looks like.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So being on defense would be
Republican. Being on defense is the status quo.
Basically, it's Republicans make some claim.
These people on the left want to make our country
socialist or they want to ruin this or they want
to indoctrinate your kids or whatever. And then
Democrats come out and like they get organized
very slowly on their talking points and then they
come up with something. But it's just a defense.
And then you sound defensive and Republicans
have already gotten out ahead on the issue. So
you're kind of just playing reactive politics.
The truth is, Democrats, given the disaster and
joke that is the Republican Party, where they
don't even pretend to be about policy anymore,
the Democrats could put together a much more
proactive strategy to create and take control
of the news cycle, pointing out all the ways
in which Republicans, if they got their way,
would actively worsen the country for large
swaths of people. So there's no it's not
a there's no hidden message is just Democrats
need to be more proactive rather than reactive.
Speaker 2: Hmm. I see. And one last question.
Sure. I'm wondering if you and the mods or
whoever it is are planning on having another chess
tournament. Because I actually found you through.
Chess.com are champions, I think.
Speaker 1: PUBG champs. Yes. Well,
that was a tournament that I organized. I'm open
to doing another chess tournament. We're just
so busy and we have so many different things,
including the children's book coming out soon
and others. I would gladly do another chess
tournament, but it's on a list of many things
that we would like to do, if that's fair.
Speaker 2: Of course. All right. Well,
thanks a lot, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
Keeton from San Jose, great to hear from you.